okay sorry can any everyone see my
screen
yes okay perfect so let me talk about
chasing comics functions
and uh i'll mostly talk about it as
almost like a survey
but maybe i'll mention a few details of
some algorithms so
let's get right to it so i'll tell you
about this problem so you're given a
point
and at each step you're given a convex
set so in this case say dimension is two
and you're given a point and your task
is to move the point within the convex
site
and the cost you pay is the cost you
move and this is what you want to
minimize
so once you move in you're going to be
given a new convex set
and once again you have to move within
the new convex set
so again the algorithm moves and this
time it pays a cost of 2.
so we continue this process and at the
end of all the requests
we look at the total movement costs okay
so in this case that the algorithm moved
a total of 16.
whereas what we want to compare
ourselves to is the optimal algorithm so
this is an
algorithm that would know all the
requests in hindsight
and it can sort of plan the trajectory
optimally so in this case it would take
this red trajectory
and it only pays a total cost of 11.
okay so let me make the problem a bit
more formal this is called the
convex body chasing problem here you're
going to be given convex that's k1 from
k2 kt all of them appear online so you
see one request after the next
and you'll have to make a decision
before seeing the next request
the decision you make is the points you
play so how you move your point
and you need to satisfy the condition
that you the point x i
is within convex set ki and what you
want to minimize
is the sum of the movement costs so in
this case i'm going to minimize the l2
norm
and what we want to look at is
minimizing the competitive ratio
okay so this is the ratio of the cost of
the algorithm to the cost of the optimal
solution
so let me also just mention that there's
a particularly important special case
which is what happens if the convex sets
are nested
so maybe this is the picture that you
want to keep in mind so each convex set
belongs to the previous one
okay so the title was chasing convex
functions so why did i talk about convex
bodies
and the reason is that we can
actually consider the convex function
chasing and convict's body chasing to be
equivalent
so one direction is somewhat easy we can
just set these convex functions to be
zero on the convex set and infinity
everywhere
sorry one thing i should mention is that
the cost now changes you also pay the
hit cost of the convex function
and this sort of reduction was actually
given in the paper of sebastian's
and they showed that these two are
essentially equivalent up to
a constant factor so it suffices to just
focus on the convex body chasing case
so what i'm going to do is i'll just
talk briefly about
so there's a lot of history in this
problem so one thing is that this
problem was introduced by lineal and
friedman in 92
almost 30 years ago and in that paper
they immediately gave a square of d
lower bound
and there's been a lot of work
especially recently regarding this
problem
um and maybe i'll just mention a few key
highlights
so one thing is that recently there was
a decompetitive algorithm and i'll just
talk about that
so the main sort of result i want to say
is that
uh there's this work function steiner
point algorithm and it achieves a d
competitive algorithm for chasing convex
bodies okay
i since this is only a 10 minute talk
what i'll do is i'll just talk about
uh what the different terms mean what a
work function is what standard point is
and that's about it
so this was um so let me just start with
the standard point and this was sort of
uh
i introduced by blue background
in sort of a seminal paper
and what the steiner point is it's an
average of the extreme points in all
directions
okay so what you do is you sample a
direction uniformly at random you look
at the extreme point
and then you average all these extreme
points
and they gave this really beautiful
algorithm it's sort of a one-line
algorithm
that says that take the standard point
and
sorry give it any convex set take the
standard point of that convex set and
just play that
okay and what they proved is that if the
convex bodies are nested
then this algorithm is decompositive and
this is a remarkable algorithm because
it doesn't really care about history
it's completely memoryless
and both the algorithm and the proof are
sort of like half a page so it's really
a beautiful paper
and once this paper came in it sort of
influenced all the work that
subsequently has come in
and what i want to say is that it's sort
of natural question to ask can we reduce
the general case to this very special
case
okay and to do that i'll need to sort of
introduce another
idea this was the other part of the
title which is work functions
so work functions are sort of a somewhat
natural concept they say okay what's
given a point why what's the minimum
cost of satisfying all the requests and
ending up at y
okay and so here's an example maybe you
have only one convex set
you're given a point y if that point is
outside the convex set you'll first need
to go
into the convex set and then come out so
you have to satisfy the request and then
go to y
so in this case if y is outside you
would pay a total cost of five
whereas if you looked at a point z
inside the convex set you would just go
directly to
okay and let me just give you a few
more insights so one thing is that to
look at this we look at the level sets
of the work function
so what that means is supposing somebody
told you what opt was
you would say okay let me look at all
the points where the work function is
less than
twice the opt okay so this is some sort
of an expanded version of opt
so in this situation let's say k is your
set and omega
is your omega would be the set of all
points where you can get to
that point while at most paying twice
the optimal cost
and now i can tell you what this
algorithm is so the algorithm
is the following after you get every
step
after you get a new point kt you compute
this set omega
t which is sort of like this expanded
version of opt
and then you play the steiner point of
this function and it turns out that this
is decompositive i won't really have
time to talk about the analysis but
maybe i'll mention
that mark sulky had
another way of combining work functions
and standard points in a very elegant
manner
and what he said was he said um instead
of taking these work functions and
looking at level sets
i'll just take i'll just define what the
standard point should be for a convex
function
it really doesn't matter what this
definition is i think the main point is
that it's natural generalization so if
you give it indicators of convex sets
this will turn out to be the standard
point of the original problem
and he also showed his proof shows that
actually the two algorithms are
equivalent
but his proof is a little stronger in
the sense that he gets uh decompetitive
for all lp norms
okay so this is very interesting but one
sort of
question that might arise is that okay
these
um in modern machine learning for
example
these functions f have very large
dimensions so can we somehow like
get better and friedman and lineal
showed that you can't do better than
square root d
so maybe what we can do is we can maybe
ask for better results when the
functions have structure
so that's something else we looked at
which is we look at functions that are
well conditioned so
if your function is alpha strongly
convex and beta smooth
there's something called the condition
number which is the ratio of these two
and the closer this is to one tells you
how smooth the function is
and in this very uh in this sort of
setting what we show is that
you can get a square root kappa
competitive algorithm
and again in this case we showed that
there's a lower bound of kappa to the
one-third
okay so there's been a lot of recent
work on this
and i'll mention maybe one other strand
of work and this was done by bubek
robani and sulky and what they said was
okay maybe you're
looking at convex function chasing where
one point
thank you and what we consider what they
consider is rather
uh what if you have multiple points and
what they showed is that even with two
points
and two dimensions you can't really do
hope to do better but if your functions
come from some special classes
like k-means or k-medians then this
becomes tractable and lastly maybe i'll
just mention that there are lots of
still
open questions in the area but sort of
the main ones are can we close this gap
for general chasing which is
can we do better than o d in the upper
bound
at least that's what most people believe
is the correct answer
and similarly if you're a well
conditioned maybe we can do better than
the square root kappa and get closer to
this cap out of the one-third
so lastly i'll just briefly mention that
i work at google research mountain view
google research is enormous there's lots
of different participants but even in
mountain view
we have a strong theory presence and we
sort of focus on all kinds of things
i'll just mention three things
algorithmic game theory online
algorithms and discrete algorithms and
there's many of us on the call so if
you're
interested we'd love to talk to you
thanks